this video is brought to you by
brilliant the best way to learn math
data science and computer science
interactively deep in the forests of
Central and South America some of the
world's deadliest organisms lurk these
creatures contain such toxic chemicals
that only a tiny dose is needed for them
to kill a full grown human poison dart
frogs might be bright cute minuscule
amphibians but they are absolutely
Nature's version of around and find out
just 2/10 of a microgram of poison could
kill a human making this organism 100
times more lethal than the deadly inland
taipan snake and there's absolutely no
antidote to their poison no treatment to
save you from a painful death and
they're not exactly trying to sneak up
on anyone through the use of camouflage
in fact they're downright flamboyant
their colors serving as a warning to
wouldbe predators
the deadliest of the family of poison
dart frogs is known as the golden poison
dart frog and has enough poison on its
skin to kill more than 20,000 mice this
little dude who only grows up to 47 mm
in size smaller than your thumb is
absolutely covered in betco toxins this
alkaloid poison causes complete muscle
paralysis shutting down the heart the
diaphragm and everything else within
minutes their deadly sec ations have
been used by indigenous people for
poisoned blow darts since pre-colombian
times which is what initially gave the
frogs their name these poison darts are
enough to drop monkeys and birds in
their tracks nerve paralysis is almost
instantaneous today there are several
hundred species of poison dart frogs
spread across tropical forests in
Central and South America besides the
golden poison dart frog some of the
other notable species are the strawberry
poison dart frog who whose name is too
tasty for its own good and who has a
varietal that is considered to be
wearing blue jeans there's the green and
black poison dart frog which looks like
a chocolate mint situation and the dying
poison dart frog which gives a sort of
Sour Warhead Vibe other of the more
deadly species are the splashback poison
frog the granular poison frog and the
fantasmal poison frog and all of these
frogs are the most forbidden snacks of
all because among the hundreds of
species are hundreds more types of
alkaloids many of which are deadly some
of which were unknown to science before
researchers started studying these frogs
and yet poison dart frogs don't make
these toxins themselves they collect
them from their prey arthropods like
ants mites and millipedes but how is it
that they can eat things that are full
of such brutal poisons and how do these
frogs avoid poisoning themselves and how
is it that Predators know to avoid these
tiny colorful frogs of
death poison dart frogs are the only
vertebrate we know of in which
coloration toxicity and diet
specialization all work together the
combination of bright colors and poison
is known as
aposematism essentially the frogs
evolved to be as bright as neon signs at
the same time as they evolved to Harbor
toxic chemicals their coloration is a
warning eat me and you're in for a bad
time interestingly when the frogs are
raised in captivity and fed a diet of
fruit flies they don't develop any of
the toxins and if wild frogs are brought
into the lab and fed a non-toxic diet
they gradually lose their poison most
toxic species of animal like snakes or
jellyfish have the ability to produce
the dangerous substances on their own a
trait known as endogenous biosynthesis
the ability to eat something toxic and
harvest those substances for one's own
protection is called sequestration and
is pretty uncommon in the natural world
that's what poison dart frogs do and
they manage it in ways we don't
completely understand these frogs have
two types of glands on their skin mucus
glands and sarus glands it's the second
of these two glands that contain the
toxic alkaloids alkaloids themselves are
organic compounds that contain nitrogen
and they're not always toxic things like
caffeine nicotine and quinine are all
alkaloids and we' found plenty of uses
for them but the alkaloids on the skin
of poison dart frogs range from making
them taste bitter to mild poison to
absolutely lethal poison however only
10% of the known alkaloids on their skin
have had their sources identified in the
cases where researchers have found a
source for the toxin it's been through
through the Frog's diet one study found
that strawberry poison dart frogs were
getting a lot of their poison via
orbited mites these tiny mites are
related to spiders and scorpions but are
only about 1 mm in size and to defend
themselves from being eaten they have
their own toxic alkaloids unfortunately
for the mites those toxins are just what
the strawberry poison dart frog is
looking for the frogs collect the
alkaloids from the mites and move those
same poisons to their skin and the more
they eat the more poison they collect
other alkaloids have been traced to
certain other arthropods tricyclics from
certain beetles Spyro padin from
siphoned millipeds and the most deadly
of all betra toxins from melid beetles
and in some cases the accumulation of
toxicity for the frogs isn't linearly
additive where eating one more Beetle
equals one more dose of poison sometimes
the frogs supercharge the poison they
are collecting by modifying the
structure of the alkaloids to make them
more potent when some species of frogs
eat arthropods that have a specific
alkaloid called pumiliotoxin they're
able to selectively hydroxate it by
adding an O group and in doing so form a
new alkaloid called alop pumiliotoxin
which is five times more toxic than the
original alkaloid but the exact
mechanism for how they move these toxins
around their body is still a bit of a
mystery what we do know is that they
have poison glands near the surface of
their skin and ducts that open up and
carry the alkaloids to the surface of
the skin when a frog is attacked by a
predator and if the Predator ingests the
poison death comes swiftly many of the
dangerous alkaloids in the frog's skin
are neurotoxins That Kill by permanently
blocking nerve signal transmission to
the muscles normally nerves work by
generating electrical signals that
transmit MIT information this electrical
signal is created by the flow of ions
across their plasma membranes at rest
the inside of a neuron has a negative
charge which is created in part by
positive sodium ions being pumped out of
the cell then when a stimulus occurs the
sodium channels briefly open because
there are many more positive sodium ions
on the outside and the inside of the
neuron is negative relative to the
outside sodium ions rush into the neuron
the cell rapidly depolarizes and fires
in action potential meaning the neuron
fires its
neurotransmitters but certain toxins can
completely disrupt this process bet
trato toxin for example binds to and
irreversibly opens the sodium channels
of nerve cells this means sodium ions
can freely diffuse between the inside
and the outside of the cell and thus the
membrane potential of the cell is
removed at this point the cell becomes
electrically dead the nerve can no
longer transmit any signals which means
every single muscle becomes paralyzed
including the heart and the diaphragm
once these stop working the organism is
very dead other toxins from poison dart
frogs Target things like the
acetylcholine receptors which renders a
similar effect and what is consistently
surprising about these Mighty little
murderers is how they aren't poisoned by
their own poison
in one case scientists found certain
frogs protect themselves by changing the
configuration of The receptors on their
neurons by a single amino acid
substitution this makes it so the toxin
doesn't bind to their receptors allowing
them to continue to function normally
researchers have also found that the
golden poison dart frog has Gene
substitutions and mutations that make it
immune to the effects of betra toxins
and dozens of its other dangerous
alkaloids but what we still don't know
is how they managed to develop defenses
against so many types of alkaloids
puffer fish for example only have to
deal with
tetrodotoxin meanwhile poison dart frogs
have immunity to dozens or even hundreds
of dangerous alkaloids toxins that they
don't even produce themselves and these
poisons are so deadly that the golden
dart frog is considered to be the most
poisonous creature on earth even just
touching the golden dart frog could be
lethal especially if you have a cut on
your hand the poison could even be
strong enough to enter through your
sweat pores though I don't think many
people are willing to test that out to
know for sure but considering that this
poison is so toxic that it kills any
wouldbe predator the first time
encountering it how do Predators learn
to avoid this brightly colored death
frog given the fact that hundreds of
species of poison dart frogs evolved to
use bright coloration in combination
with poisonous skin would seem to
indicate that it's a successful strategy
and in one study scientists looking at
color variations among poison dart frogs
found that birds were more likely to
attack blue frogs than more vividly
colored yellow frogs suggesting that the
birds were a bit more worried about the
brighter yellow prey the more
conspicuous the Frog the safer it was
but if the poison is so toxic from
golden poison dart frogs that it's
lethal if ingested 100% of the time How
can any animal learn to avoid it one
possibility is that every frog has a
different level of poison juvenile frogs
for example have had less time to
accumulate poison and may not kill the
predator and instead give them a highly
unpleasant experience additionally a
predator does not need to ingest the
Frog to be harmed by its toxins a
predator with a wet nose who bumps the
Frog while sniffing it will likely have
a bad time time but perhaps not die
these situations could allow the
Predator to learn from past experience
that bright frog is Bad Frog and Beyond
this for some predators avoiding
brightly colored animals May Simply Be
hardwired genetically over millions of
years predators that were more inclined
to avoid brightly colored prey survived
more often but what about Predators who
don't even have color vision like the
bullet ant and bromad spiders
both of these arthropods are big enough
to prey on small frogs and are known to
do so on a fairly regular basis they
also don't rely on color vision when
they're hunting do they know to avoid
the dangerous frogs researchers
presented bullet ants and bromad spiders
with two species of frog the non-toxic
bransfords litter frog and the toxic
strawberry dart frog bullet ants would
eat juveniles of the strawberry dart
frog but not the adults and the spiders
wouldn't touch any of the toxic frogs no
matter their age even though they did
eat the non-toxic species these
Predators still knew which frogs to
avoid likely using meano and chemo
reception but the poisonous frogs can't
always be so certain that they're safe
from predation one species of snake
called the fire-bellied snake has
evolved a resistance to betco toxins in
the golden poison dart frog it's the
only known predator of this frog and the
Royal ground snake another species in
the same snake genus was observed to
attack and kill three striped poison
frogs it was the first time this
Behavior has ever been seen in the wild
so researchers will need to do a lot
more investigation but it does suggest
something of an arms race between
predators and the poison dart frogs but
as dangerous as these frogs might be to
Predators they are not Invincible even
with their chemical Arsenal about a
quarter order of poison dart frog
species are classified as endangered or
critically endangered and that comes
down to habitat loss fungal infection
and the exotic pet trade all factors
that these small frogs can't fight
against with their toxic skin but
nonetheless these small frogs punch
above their weight class in terms of
lethality and show us that even the
tiniest cutest things can be a force to
be reckoned with unfortunately for us
humans we can't can't absorb the poison
that we eat and use it as a weapon but
there is something else that we can
absorb and that is knowledge by
understanding the genetic underpinings
of the poison dart Frog's resistance to
poison we one day might be able to learn
how to be resistant to certain poisons
ourselves by understanding the evolution
of poison dart frogs their predators and
their prey we will better understand how
to conserve them understanding biology
and the math chemistry and physics it
all entails is the best best tool we
have to protect ourselves and protect
the incredible world we live in and
surprisingly there is a free and easy
way to practice these skills brilliant
has so many courses on subjects that
help you wrap your head around the math
and science Concepts that are so
important in understanding our natural
world brilliant is the best way to learn
math data science and computer science
interactively I've always struggled with
lectures and textbooks but brilliant is
an Interactive Learning environment
where lessons are structured around
things that feel more like games and
puzzles than like college coursework
there are levers slides and buttons so
you can test theories and visualize
highlevel Math and Science Concepts the
computational biology course has been
particularly helpful for me to see how
mathematical modeling and computational
simulations can help us understand
biological systems protein folding for
example is one of the most difficult
things to understand and predict in the
natural world but the protein origami
lesson in this course walks you through
the foundational experiments in
computational biology that have allowed
the Science World to take a huge leap
forward in understanding this mysterious
process the pictures diagrams and
interactivity helped me finally grasp
something that I always thought was too
complicated for me to understand
brilliant has thousands of lessons like
this from foundational and advanced math
to AI data science neural networks and
more with new lessons added monthly so
to better learn how to confidently
navigate this world of overwhelming
numbers and to try everything brilliant
has to offer free for a full 30 days
visit brilliant.org sreal science or
click on the link in the description the
first 200 people will get 20% off
Brilliance annual premium subscription
and every sign up helps this
[Music]
channel